I would love to introduce you
to three remarkable women I know.
Meet Jane Maigua,
Charity Wangui and Loise Maina.
Now, these three women
are restoration champions.
They started a company six years ago
in my hometown of Nairobi,
purchasing macadamia nuts from farmers,
processing them and selling them
around the world.
Today, Exotic EPZ is in partnership
with 9,000 farmers across the country.
Imagine for a minute
the tree-growing movement
these women could catalyze across Kenya.
Now here's another group
of women that I absolutely adore.
These are the women of Maragua.
These women are discovering
the wonders of bamboo.
They are planting bamboo and sharing
across their communities.
They're using bamboo for entrepreneurship.
They're using bamboo for restoration,
and they're using it for firewood.
Now these restoration champions
have something in common.
They are using nature to reduce poverty,
accelerate the re-greening of Africa
and secure livelihoods.
Now, this is part of the AFR100 Movement
an Africa-wide initiative to restore
100 million hectares of land
by 2030.
All on a continent where we know
60 percent of soils are degraded.
And this is only the beginning
because the restoration
potential in Africa
is 750 million hectares,
equal to the size landmass of Australia.
And this on a continent
where 60 percent of the land is degraded.
Now, why is this important?
This is because restoration
breaks the cycle of degradation.
It is at once about climate mitigation
and cushioning communities against
the worst impacts of climate change.
My organization, the World
Resources Institute,
is working with AFR100 very closely.
We are helping them to raise resources
needed for restoration,
to accelerate the establishment
of sound policies
so that restoration is incentivized.
And also establishing
platforms like this one,
so restoration champions
have the platforms and there’s training
that they need to accelerate restoration.
Now without these local leaders,
local wisdom, local knowledge
and the passion that drives
restoration champions,
scaling restoration
on the African continent
would virtually be impossible.
Now, my name is Wanjira Mathai,
and I have a personal connection to trees.
When we were growing up,
my brothers and I,
our mother, Wangari Mathai,
who founded the Green Belt Movement
and won the 2004 Nobel
Peace Prize for this work --
(Applause)
Thank you.
She spent hours
sharing just how beautiful Kenya was
when she was growing up.
The river’s, crystal clear.
The hillsides and valleys,
covered in forests.
The plains were teeming with wildlife
and the soils, she would say,
produced the most delicious
sweet potatoes and vegetables.
Hunger was virtually unknown.
By the 1970s, a lot had changed.
Landscapes were already degraded,
rivers were silted with precious topsoil.
The plains were already
losing their wildlife,
and the soils were largely degraded.
Now, half a century on,
and the process of degradation
has only accelerated.
And not only in Kenya.
27 of the 40 most climate-vulnerable
countries in the world
are found on the African continent.
And hunger and drought,
for those farmers, 60 percent of them
who live on the African continent,
is an everyday occurrence.
But why is this important?
Why is this important?
Because restoration reverses
and breaks the cycle of degradation.
And there is hope.
Because here is an example,
the Green Belt Movement.
The Green Belt Movement is an example
of a restoration champion in Kenya.
50 million trees planted
by a network of 5,000 women today.
And they do this by organizing
themselves into groups,
generating tree nurseries,
collecting seeds themselves that they sow,
generate seedlings and plant
on public land and private land.
This is the genius
of restoration champions.
Now, I have seen this work firsthand
in a forest not too far from where I live,
the Aberdare Forest.
This is one of my favorite forests.
A few years ago it was degraded,
but thanks to the pioneering work
of the Green Belt Movement
and many others like them,
this forest has largely been restored.
And I love spending time in this forest
because as far
as the eye can see are trees.
You could almost see them drawing out
carbon dioxide and pumping out oxygen,
holding on to precious topsoil.
And the crystal clear waterfalls
that supply the rivers of Nairobi,
the city where I live.
AFR100 will take practices like these
across the African continent
and replicate them
not merely to halt deforestation,
but to reverse it.
Because that's what is needed.
Now, it's not uncommon for people to say
that initiatives like those
supported by AFR100
are too small or too risky
for meaningful investments.
But our work at AFR100 shows
that not only are these initiatives
economical and transformative,
they make financial sense.
Our research also shows
that initiatives like these
that are locally led and managed
are 20 times more likely
to deliver long-term success.
And they are also more likely to deliver
economic and environmental benefits.
So if we invest in initiatives
like Tilaa in Ghana,
AFR100,
the Green Belt movement,
GreenPort in Kenya and ARCOS in Rwanda,
they will in turn invest in thousands
and thousands of restoration champions
who will restore their landscapes
and restore their livelihoods.
Now, this is exactly the sort of inclusive
transformation we need to see
across the African continent.
Now all my life,
I was made acutely aware
of just how precious
green vegetation truly is.
Nature is the source of everything good
my mother would tell me all the time.
You see, this vision we have
to re-green the African continent,
it's not only possible,
it is vital.
It is our life support system.
Now, many of us here despair
that we are the generation
that is destroying the planet.
But we don't have to be.
We can be the restoration generation.
Thank you.
(Applause)